hi I'm Kristen Goodwin on this episode
of the Fox News rundown as health
officials around the world work to
contain the threat of the corona virus
there are concerns over the economic
costs and whether the outbreak could
disrupt phase one of the us-china trade
deal host lisa brady chats with liz
claman anchor of countdown to the
closing bell on the Fox Business Network
to discuss how the illness could impact
global and US economies between the Iowa
caucus debacle and the president's
victory lap after being acquitted by the
Senate one could argue it wasn't an easy
week for Democrats Democratic
presidential candidates will take the
debate stage this evening in New
Hampshire days before the state's
primary Fox News political analyst Juan
Williams joins host Dave Anthony with a
preview and a breakdown of the
presidential race plus commentary from
Fox News contributor and former Utah
Republican congressman jason Chaffetz
the Fox News rundown is a Daily News
podcast where we take a deeper look at
the stories important to you you can
subscribe on your favorite podcast
player by going to FoxNews podcast.com
I'm Juan Williams I'm Gerry Willis I'm
Bill Hemmer and this is the Fox News
rundown
Friday February 7th 2020 and Lisa Brady
as the corona virus continues to spread
countries and companies race for the
economic impact we are seeing company
after company after company already
seeing the effect and warning investors
about it I'm Dave Anthony seven
Democrats running for president get the
spotlight again tonight with a debate
after the mess in Iowa and before the
next contest in New Hampshire I expect
that Biden has to be more aggressive
I expect that Budaj eggs will be
trumpeting himself now as a leader and
similarly Sanders has every reason to
say he's a leader in this game and I'm
jason Chaffetz I've got the final word
on the Fox News rundown
[Music]
the rapid spread of the new corona virus
has not only sickened thousands of
people killing hundreds it's impacting
millions of lives especially in China
where quarantines have turned whole
cities into ghost towns nobody outside
no trains no subways no cars are not on
the road
Jared Evans plays pro football in
China's National League for the team
based in Wuhan the epicenter of the
outbreak he's now under temporary
quarantine at a military base in
California one of the hundreds of
Americans evacuated from Wuhan on
chartered flights we definitely were
pretty much of a cargo plane very
comfortable everybody was wearing masks
and taking major precautions and some of
the also the officials were in a
complete hazmat suit checking out
temperature every three to four hours
but as health officials searched for
answers treat patients and try to stop
the spread a wide variety of industries
are dealing with ripple effects when you
think about every item that you have in
your house list claim in is hosed of the
claim and countdown on fox business
whether it is your Alexa or your table
and chairs or your heating system and
air conditioning system I could probably
guarantee that at some point the supply
chain that came together to make those
products went somewhere through or touch
China some house so it is no surprise
that there is a domino effect going on
with companies like tapestry the parent
of Coach or Apple's air Potts you know
the latest news is that the companies
that supply the components for air pods
these are companies like Lux shared ger
tech invent ech they are at most looking
at two weeks left of inventory in
component parts for the assembly of air
pots so you might think that nothing
goes through China or you'll hear at CEO
say well we don't have exposure you
actually probably do yeah there was even
an auto parts issue raised by Fiat
Chrysler one of their European plants is
saying that they could have weeks of
delays because of parts issues because
millions of people in
China some of them workers in these
industries are basically quarantined
well let's just make something really
clear people are hearing the name Wuhan
and who Bay province the the little
known fact about those areas the
province and then of course the city
within the province is that it is huge
when it comes to auto parts and auto
manufacturing
so what Fiat Chrysler is now saying is
that they are weeks away from having to
idle a European plant and that is
because they can't get the parts or the
products that go through or are
manufactured in hebei province to their
plants to actually make the cars Tesla
is closing stores you're hearing of a
lot of these companies who either have
to shutter their plants that are on the
ground in China or they're shuttering
plants that aren't even in China because
they need the parts that were
manufactured in Hebei province and
there's some intangibles too in terms of
profits and a good example might be with
the Oscars coming up this weekend
I think they shut down like 70,000
theaters in China and maybe that's just
in China but that's a big market for
Hollywood imax was one of the first to
say how it would be affected IMAX of
course the huge screen a theater company
and they have a bunch of on-the-ground
screens in China people rushed to see
movies there that tickets they'll pay
anything for it well they've had to put
off their actual slate of Chinese movies
that were supposed to come out roaring
out during the Chinese New Year which is
their biggest season so they were among
the first and now they're shuttering
along with a lot of other companies and
theaters because you can't have groups
of people who are breathing all over
each other you know we're sharing
popcorn who knows but I think what's
really important to stress here is that
we are unknown anybody who says we
understand what our future is going to
look like at the moment
estee lauder actually called it
immediately and they said we will
meaningfully have to cut our outlook
because the virus will dent demand and
luxury products but yet you hear a lot
of people saying it's too early to tell
what the effect is I'm here to tell her
buddy we are seeing company after
company after company already seeing the
effect and warning investors about it
yeah because we don't we don't even know
if it's peaked the World Health
Organization is saying on Wednesday it
was the first day that the number of new
cases in China at least went down
instead of up but that's one day so with
the you know just at this point there
are too many unknowns with how long it
could last
I think if memory serves but I want to
ask you because you'll know for sure
I think the first stocks to really get
impacted by this when it first really
started making big headlines in the last
few weeks were airline and travel
related and IMAX I mean I remember
several weeks ago reading about IMAX I'm
thinking well this is kind of serious
because everything was slowing down or
grinding to a halt during the Chinese
New Year which was a very significant
time but yes the airline's of course
started to get impacted and what is it a
little bit confusing for investors is
they started to rally once again
recently and yet you have thousands and
thousands of ticket holders who bought
return tickets to the United States or
other countries holding those tickets
there on the ground in China and
airlines like American are no longer
flying I talked to a source at American
who said that they had thousands of
ticket holders on the ground in China
waiting to get out but you know their
pilots Union sued to stop the airline
from flying in and out of that region
because it was dangerous they fell to
their own pilots so what happens to all
those people are we going to see mass
military air lifts and and again these
huge question marks and yet some people
believe that it is not going to be
anywhere near as bad as first thought
and therefore you're looking at stock
markets hitting record after record so
far the Trump administration is
downplaying the impact to the US economy
at this point we haven't seen big issues
in regards to supply chains but US
Treasury Chief Steve minuchin and the
president's top economic advisor Larry
Kudlow each told mornings with Maria
this week it could impact the trade deal
with China
is true the trade deal the phase one
trade deal the export boom from that
trade deal will take longer because of
the Chinese virus that is true that
phase one deal signed last month
includes a kind of pause clause making
it possible for China to delay its end
of the bargain
the pause Clause says pending market
conditions or dependent upon market
conditions and this is really crucial
because when you're talking about market
conditions scénic which is the Chinese
oil company has declared force majeure
on LNG contracts meaning they're saying
due to this force majeure is French for
a major force that was unforeseen and
unexpected and a total negative surprise
we won't be able to pay for those
contracts right now and therefore will
be off the hook because we're declaring
force majeure it's almost like there was
a force majeure contract in phase 1 or
at least that pause clause so we don't
know what's going to happen although
China has not yet signified that they
would back down from buying the billions
that they promised to buy from America
whether it was agricultural products or
basic materials and and other handmade
products it seems I would think to put
the u.s. in a bit of a tougher spot with
the ongoing talks to because you're you
don't want to seem like you're
capitalizing on their misfortune the
Chinese are incredibly smart in multiple
ways one of them is they're not going to
do what they don't want to do and
clearly when they signed phase 1 they
were ready they were ready to cry uncle
their economy was hurting
way more than ours due to the trade war
so they made these promises but they did
put in the market conditions issue and
it was sort of they're out in case and
also Brazilian soybeans are less
expensive than American soybeans well
when you're picking vendors you're gonna
go with the Brazilians you're gonna go
with the lesser expensive one well the
promise was to buy from us soybean
farmers it just will be very interesting
to see if this gets worse and the
coronavirus continues to claim lives and
personally and I speak only for myself I
do not believe the numbers
I think the Chinese are very much under
reporting the numbers once the true
numbers come out who knows all bets will
be off because the Chinese government is
in full swing
trying to build hospitals in a week and
a half they're trying to stop this thing
what's the important thing right now for
us consumers and investors to bear in
mind because we don't really have
control over writing this thing out
when you say ride that's a perfect way
of saying it but writing what is it a
smooth bicycle ride or a surfboard I
would say it is a surfboard in very
choppy surf so what you have to do is
hold on tight and do not trade day to
day unless you feel like it and you're
one of these you know traders that
figures out oh I could I could make a
buck here and there you know most of us
have day jobs just sit tight and if
there is a meaningful drop hopefully
you've got a shopping list of stocks
that were too expensive up until then
and maybe you pick up a few shares here
and there of companies that are great
but going through a tough time
always the calming voice of reason for
liz claman host of the claim and
countdown on fox business also check out
her podcast everyone talks to Liz I love
getting to talk to you thank you so much
it's my pleasure thank you
this is jason chaffetz with your foxnews
commentary coming up four days before
the next contest Iowa is no longer in
focus in the Democratic race for
presidents I don't be able to count your
votes Bernie Sanders and Peabody Judge
came away the big winners from the chaos
of the caucuses we are going on to New
Hampshire victorious tonight they'll be
on stage in New Hampshire for the next
democratic debate before Tuesday's
primary so will Joe Biden who finished
fourth
we took a gut punch in Iowa the whole
process took a gut punch but look this
is the first time in my life I've been
knocked down Elizabeth Warren who was
third and Iowa will also be their sole
Amy Klobuchar who had a 5th place finish
Tom Steyer and Andrew yang who ended up
with nothing in Iowa will also be
debating tonight this will be the last
debate without Michael Bloomberg Juan
Williams is a Fox News political analyst
co-host of the five on the Fox News
Channel and I think that may have been
the biggest news of the last few days is
that Bloomberg doubled down on the
amount of money he's putting into ads
and the DNC rules now after the first
vote have changed so that even though
Michael Bloomberg has not taken money
from any donors he will be eligible to
be on the stage for the subsequent
debate yeah there are two more this
month right one in Nevada and one in
South Carolina right right so but for
Nevada
you will meet Michael Bloomberg on the
Democratic Party debate stage yeah so I
just wanted to point that out now as to
the state of the race apart from the
fact that Bloomberg is doubling down and
his ads can be seen everywhere I think
what we saw in Iowa was the emergence of
people attached I don't think there's
any question that was the big surprise
some might say well Biden slipping to
fourth what he called a gut punch was a
surprise but you remember Biden
initially wasn't competing in Iowa he
was pursuing something like a Bloomberg
strategy which was you know what I was
okay we'll start really getting going in
New Hampshire and then his firewall all
along was
Nevada South Carolina and that stands
right now people are dumping on Biden
suggesting oh what a disappointment of
course he's been under an onslaught from
the president and where's hunter and all
that but Biden still leads in the
national polls Dave and I think
sometimes people lose track of it but
the national polls do they really matter
it's like well the reason I say that is
because you have these these contests
that are done individually by different
states we've had Iowa that was a mess
but individually we're focused on New
Hampshire next so we don't do a national
vote ever for the Democrats
so do that does that poll really matter
it should matter actually you make a
very interesting point because one of
the problems Joe Biden's having is money
I don't know if you've noticed but he is
right now financially challenged as I
say so if he finishes fourth in New
Hampshire does that make it harder to go
out and say hey give me some money well
that's that's what I'm saying you know
it's almost like I'm not sure here
because in fact often times buy and then
others will point to national polls in
terms of fundraising especially with
Super Tuesday coming when 40% of the
delegates will be selected you have
states like California Texas big states
involved on that day so that the
national polls do matter in my mind I
understand what you're saying about the
individual states but remember in these
individual states you're really talking
about media momentum that's why the
screw up in Iowa hurt someone like Pete
Buddha James hurt Bernie Sanders because
they came out on top and they should
have gotten a huge bounce instead the
big story was chaos yeah Democrats can't
count alternatively people have said
that that was also helpful to Biden
because of all that focus on the chaos
not only did Bernie in P Buda judge not
get the bump up but there wasn't as much
focus on wow he did that exactly and it
makes you think that he's looking for
something Bill Clinton really branded
the comeback kid he's looking for that
and I think he might get it I don't know
how close he'll come in New Hampshire
but I expect if I was putting money down
today that he'll be second in New
Hampshire hmm cuz Buddha judge in the
latest two polls that came out
that was Biden at 12% right and that
that's that's not close to winning New
Hampshire no I think Sanders will
clearly win New Hampshire I think Warren
might do well but I'm thinking that
Biden will be right there and I'll be
very close and then you get into Nevada
and South Carolina and I expect
providing to survive he's got to win in
both otherwise by the way Budaj
gets a leg up in terms of that centrist
lane and Michael Bloomberg then emerges
you have often talked that Peabody judge
has not much outside of these first two
contests South Carolina nothing nothing
Nevada yeah is he busy is he doing
anything after let's say let's go to
February 12 primaries over in New
Hampshire where does he go does he go to
Nevada and say I'm one of the majors he
can and I think he has to do that in
terms of sort of representing and making
the case that he's still a player he's
got to ride a wave if he has won yeah I
don't think it's gonna have much of a
wave there though unless something
changes in the dynamic markedly changed
so nothing in Nevada and nothing in
South Carolina one for Tuesday so he has
to focus on that like Bloomberg big-time
okay one of the things that's going on
among Democrats Davis I think there's a
certain level of especially right before
and especially after Iowa a certain
despondency like hey why don't we have
somebody who has emerged at this point
who is like got magic dust sprinkled on
them it looks like they're special and
different and the Bernie bros think
that's him you know I don't know I I got
to tell you that the Trump campaign
loves Bernie Sanders and I think it's
clear in both cases though Warren or
Sanders that it fits into the Republican
riff about socialists communists but
clearly they're afraid of Joe Biden
that's what this whole Ukraine thing was
about getting dirt on Joe Biden and I
think there's somewhat afraid of Michael
Bloomberg because he has such deep
pockets
does Elizabeth Warren have to do tonight
in your opinion this is a tough one now
she comes from a neighboring state in
Massachusetts
I expect that Biden has to be more
aggressive
I expect that Buddha's eggs will be
trumpeting himself now as a leader and
similarly Sanders has every reason to
say he's a leader in this game one I
don't know how she distinguishes herself
from Bernie unless she is able to say
bernie is not electable and I am if she
can somehow convey that effectively I
think this will be a good debate for her
Tom Styer we talked about the surprise
he had in polls recently in Nevada and
South Carolina two big states coming up
obviously tonight he's going to be
looking ahead to those contests he's not
really a player in New Hampshire what do
you think he does seeming that the same
thing he's always been doing I think so
I don't see much difference here the
question would be the amount of money he
wants to spend and he spent a good penny
already but much of it on the idea of
impeaching Donald Trump now that that's
in the past where does he go with that
money Bloomberg has been very clear in
the ad Bloomberg ran during the
Superbowl was about guns
Tom Stiers thing is the environment is
that enough to energize the party and
raise him up California maybe now and
react he in the initial preference got
about 5% or so in Iowa course not enough
to get to the second because he added
15% so he hardly had anything come out
of Iowa we spent a lot of time there is
he almost done in your opinion yes but I
don't know that he knows that he might
still think you know he's having a good
time he's raising his profile he has
really done a terrific job for himself
is it a winning job that's a different
standard and I don't see that he is
going to break out obviously you have a
larger Asian population in California
than you do in Iowa and New Hampshire
and I think they're very proud of Andrew
yang and what he's done but is that
enough to really elevate him to make him
someone who you would say is going to
finish in the top three I
don't see it as we sit here Amy
Klobuchar did fairly well in Iowa what
is she doing next I think again this is
the centrist lane so much in this is
premise town the idea that Joe Biden
implodes if he implodes then Buddha
judge has an even bigger road to victory
Bloomberg comes in and challenges Buddha
judge and here comes Warren and
Klobuchar the difference is Warren is
more to the left Klobuchar more to the
center and the lone woman that would
occupy that center lane is clove of char
in an audition for Vice President easily
easily I think that the problem here is
have you've noticed and you'll see it of
tonight on the stage there are no people
of color and the logic had been well
we're gonna have to have somebody there
because we can't just take for granted
the black the Latino vote and beat
Donald Trump you've got to have an
energized base last time with Hillary
Hillary does great in terms of the
percentage of the vote that she gets
from people of color and women
especially women of color but there was
a slight decline in terms of turnout
from the Obama years with of course the
first african-american president on the
ballot understandable but critical in
those swing states if you look at a city
like Milwaukee if you look at a city
like Detroit if those numbers had been
elevated Hillary would have won the
electoral college she lost in even
Pennsylvania in Philadelphia by very
narrow margin all three states less than
a hundred thousand votes all three of
those big cities with large
african-american populations if she can
get that if they can the Democrats can
get that back up again it's gonna make a
big difference in the logic is what
about Kamala Harris senator from
California who had been on the stage is
now gone a lot of talk about her
endorsing Biden early so as to get her
feet in that place Klobuchar though I
think you're right I think you know if
she's not vice president she could be
you know Secretary of State she could
she has made herself a
forest in the Democratic Party than ever
quick last tonight does the debate
matter for the voters in New Hampshire
and could it affect the outcome in your
opinion oh yeah and I'm gonna go up to
New Hampshire to see the debate and all
the rest they're gonna pay attention to
that debate they're gonna meet the
candidates and to them it makes a huge
difference
Juan Williams co-host of the five Fox
News political analyst thanks so much
for joining us my pleasure thanks for
having
[Music]
it's the Perino and steyr Walt I'll tell
you what podcast Dana Perino of the five
and Fox News political editor Chris
Stein watch Isaac the ins and outs of
national politics subscribe and listen
now by going to fox news podcasts com
now some good news with Tonya J powers
even the world's worst cat deserves a
home that's what perdida a cat from the
mitchell county north carolina Animal
Rescue has become known as the rescue
was trying to find her a home so they
posted on Facebook about her under the
heading world's worst cat instead of
sugarcoating purr Dita's disposition
rescue officials just laid it all out
there it red meat Perdita not for the
faint of heart
we thought she was sick turns out and
she's just a jerk likes include staring
into your soul until you feel as if you
may never be cheerful again this song
cat scratch fever jump scares they're
her specialty lurking in dark corners
being queen of her domicile fooling
shelter staff into thinking she's sick
the vet agrees she's just a jerk
dislikes are the color pink kittens dogs
children the Dixie Chicks Disney movies
Christmas and last but not least hugs
the rescue even posted a video of a
shelter volunteer trying to fix Purdy
does blanket and sticking a hand inside
her enclosure
I'm not gonna take I'm sorry I just
trying to straighten you up I love you
that was a hiss of displeasure there in
case you missed it about halfway through
the rescue his use of candor and humor
paid off and they got more than 175
applications to adopt Perdita they
finally settled on Joe and Betty a
couple from Monroe County Tennessee
they've changed per Dita's name to Noel
the rescue announced just in case the
name Perdita was the cause of her anger
they wanted to get a picture for social
media but say no L wouldn't let them
take any growling and running out of the
room
[Music]
Tania J powers Fox News
[Music]
it's time for your Fox News commentary
and Chaffetz what's on your mind
drunk derangement syndrome has reached
new heights the Democratic Party has
routinely chastised the president for
not bringing our country together
ironically it is the Democrats who
frequently don't even show up
it started with over 60 Democrats
boycotting Trump's inauguration it
continued with the budget discussions
and it happened again at the State of
the Union this year at least ten
Democrats including representative
Alexandria
Acacio Cortes the Democrat from New York
refused to attend and at least two
walked out during the speech well that's
mature and productive I suppose that
means being present to honor the
promotion in service of 100 year old
Charles Magee
one of the last Tuskegee Airmen was a
waste of the Democrats time the
Brigadier General flew more than 130
combat missions in world war ii and
further served in korea and vietnam he
was in the audience and his grandson who
hoped to one day join the United States
space force but that wasn't worthy of
the congressman's time and when Pelosi
dramatically ripped up the speech given
by the president she was once again
refusing to lead an opposition of ideas
with the dignity needed and worthy of
the office of the speaker her antics
brought us new lows and stripped her of
any moral high-ground to ever chastise a
president who has brought our country
amazing success at home and abroad
she has elected to demean the position
of speaker and embarrass an already
disrespected institution
she may have ripped up the speech in a
fit of immaturity and desperation
thinking it was another political stunt
sure to please her base but it was
hardly the action of a leader and
certainly not a speaker i'm jason
Chaffetz
you have been listening to the FoxNews
rundown stay up to date by subscribing
the Fox News radios hourly newscast at
FoxNews podcasts dot-com and for
up-to-the-minute news visit Fox news.com
[Music]